with almost 500 sessions annex 2018 it's
understandable you couldn't get to them
all so if you didn't see how Google
enabled rapid response to meltdown
inspector then stay tuned because here's
the rewind Google's cloud handles global
scale traffic and tremendous workloads
all while maintaining security for you
and your data so when big security
challenges like specter and meltdown
come around our architecture needs to
help us respond quickly and adapt to
these new issues having the right
infrastructure design lets us move
quickly to respond to new threats and
make changes across the large-scale
fleet efficiently in the last year we
had to address new discoveries that
impacted the entire industry appearing
at the processor level to start let's
dig into the technology behind the
platform and how that creates a secure
environment Google's cloud technologies
are built with defense-in-depth in mind
applying nine layers of security
starting from the hardware moving all
the way up to the individual people
using the platform for example Google
loves containers and we run all sorts of
workloads internal and external in them
every day this is great for security
because containers provide critical
safety assurances by isolating workloads
and keeping them from interacting in any
way but in some cases the limits
provided by containers are too basic
so we've adopted a two boundary rule
which states any interesting code must
be separated by two defensive barriers
that way any one new vulnerability can't
break our separation between virtual
machines beyond our VM isolation we've
improved on existing sandbox technology
with G visor which provides security
through OS level virtualization we can
reduce the vulnerability of system calls
and give us a secondary sandbox for
applications running on containers this
combination of strong defenses between
containers and lightweight VM Management
allowed us to quickly update our entire
fleet after we deployed kernel page
table isolation to combat meltdown and
ret Pauline to prevent specters branch
target injection attack we were able to
get to a secure state without noticeable
downtime or performance impact all
because we could do live migration of
VMs patch the underlying processor an OS
code then migrated the VMS back to
repeat
this process again with the next host
Google isn't the only one out there
discovering new vulnerabilities it's key
that our security teams engage with the
wider security community to share
information and fix problems so we can
all be safer together online
we started our vulnerability rewards
program in 2010 which helps benefit the
security research community through
collaboration as well as cash bonuses
google has paid out almost twelve
million dollars as of July this year and
we continue to improve and update our
prize amounts including thirty one
thousand three hundred and thirty seven
dollars for a discovered sandbox escape
ask me later about that number
we also think carefully about the people
and process of securing our cloud and
how we approach the monitoring and
response to security incident we need a
strong cycle of observe orient decide
and act with teams that span multiple
disciplines and multiple sites around
the globe so we can keep watch every
hour of every day if you'd like to see
the full talk check out the link in the
description below and don't forget to
subscribe to the cloud YouTube channel
for more great next rewind content
thanks for watching
you
[Music]